ではよろしくお願いします
今日は 2回目の話で こちらに書いてるテーマ
好きを呼ぶ人好きから見放される人の違いという
良因悪因ということで
好きという言葉は一応専門家がついた言葉で
私はあまり使わない言葉なんですけど
もしかするとまあ私が使っている日本語で言えば
ラッキーな人とあまりラッキーじゃないアンラッキーな人ってどういうものかというふうなことだと思いますけど
じゃあまあ一応そういう話だったらね
簡単なんですけど でももうちょっとお釈迦様っていうのはもうそれほど
ただ人間に簡単だから簡単なことを喋るということではなくて
事実をお話ししてあげましょうということで喋りましたので
少々難しいところもあることはあるんです
まあそこら辺 まあ理解できればそれで大変ありがたいし
難しかったらまあちょっと聞き流しちゃえばまあいいんじゃないかなと
理解できるところだけ理解していただければ
それで大変結構です で
いくら難しいと言ったっても
じっと聞いていらっしゃるならば
大体仏教の話っていうのはよく心に入るんです
で なぜならば お釈迦様はこのなんか特別な学問みたいなものを言ってるんじゃなくて
我々の心のこと言ってるんです
ですから 私のことを喋ってるんです
私の心のことっていうのは
私のことだから 私のことを喋ってるんだから
よく聞いてるとよく分かってしまうんですね
それからその知識はどういうものかと
他の世の中で知識と比べると
もう大変なレベル高いもう知識知恵にはなってしまいます
ですから この特にこの初期仏教のお釈迦様は直々自分のお口で喋った言葉なんですけどね
そういうのはじっと聞くと誰にでも理解できるんですね
で これは理解できないなと思うところは
ちゃんとお釈迦様はちゃんと注意しているんですね
そこら辺はわからないだろうと
で そういうことで で わからないだろうというところもわかるんです
でも問題はお釈迦様には我々と違った
ものすごい高次元的な知識能力ありましたから
それから見て喋っているところもあるんですね
いわゆる人間のレベル
随分乗り越えたレベルからお話ししたところもありますから
そこら辺 我々には一般的に人間にはね
ちょっと理解しにくいところがございますけど
その場合もお釈迦様おっしゃっているのは
この そのお釈迦様おっしゃっている修行方法
心の育てる方法をやってみたら
その人々の認識レベルがどうせ超次元的なレベルになるんですね
それもそんなに難しい方法ではありません
そうすると その人々に私が言っていることはわかるだろうということで
ですから たまにわからないところは出てきますが
その場合はちゃんと注意があります
ですから どんな難しい話であろうとも
これは私のことだと 私の心のこと言ってるんだという立場で聞いていただくと
あっ 何のことなく理解できるんだと思いますね
ですから このたまに何か心は痛いとかね
聞きたくないとかというふうな言葉を言うかもしれません
私が でもそれはあまり気にしないで
あの  私の心のことを言ってるんだということで聞いてみればよろしいんじゃないかなと
で 話を始まる前に申し上げたいんです
そこでテーマに入る前に
私はあの あの あの業を科学しますと申し上げましたからね
今日も残念ながら一応科学します
あの仏教の業論ですね
あのカルマのこと で こういうことを我々まず考えてみましょう
あの磁石ございますね
磁石っていうのは まあ何ものも引いちゃうんですね
何ものもではなくて あの鉄が入っているものだったら
磁石にはもう何の関係も全部引いてしまっちゃうんですね
そこで引く時の論理っていうのは
強い方が弱いものを引いちゃうんですね
例えば磁石が大きくて重いんだったら
軽い鉄は全部自分の方向に引っ張っちゃう
もし鉄分がすごく大きくて重いんだったら
磁石がそこに行ってつけてしまっちゃいますね
それで磁石にもう一つ法則があるんですね
同じ磁石だったら やっぱりあの
何て言いますか 同じ極がつけないんですね
捨てちゃうんですね そういう 2つ
ものを引くエネルギーもあって
ものを引き返すエネルギーもありますと
そういう法則を我々は今から心に当てはめてみるんです
で 心にも同じような法則があるんですね
で 似ているものはなんだかんだ引くと
それから引きたいんだけど
もし向こう側が自分の心より強いんだったら
こちらがそこに引っ張られてつけてしまうと
そういう法則があります
それをお釈迦様は四十年お経がございまして
その四十もっと以上から本当に数えたことはございませんだけど
大体勘ではそれぐらいあると思いますけど
あるテーマでお話しているんです
そのテーマはちょっと長いテーマですけど
またちょっとありますけど
一応そこら辺で略しておきます
ダハトソウはサッターサンサンダンティサメンティというまたありますけど
で意味なんですけど サッターっていうのは生命
まあ仏教専門用語で言えば衆生
サンサンラティっていうのは合いますと
よく合うと似合うと いわゆるつなげるとという意味なんです
で どのようにすればダハトソウはこのダハトっていうのはすごいややこしい言葉なんです
ダハトっていうのはこのいろんな意味で使ってまして
この元素 根本的なものという意味で一般的に使うんです
いわゆる根本的なところで人々が
衆生が 人間だけじゃないんです
生命がぴったしはめてしまうんだと
その根本的なところっていうのは
これを皆様メモをお書きになるならば
ヤフーの場合はこの性格と書いておいてください
根本的な性格によって人々が互いに合いますと
つなげてしまうんだと
あるいは群がるんだと
というタイトルでたくさんお経があるんです
その一つ一つのお経で
一つ一つの項目を分析してお話しているんですね
ですから それだけ喋るともうかなりの量になりますから
僕は単なるこのたくさんのお経のタイトルだけとって
今日ちょっと説明いたします
で 一応本で言えばちょっと冊の本ぐらいの量なんですね
で 本のタイトルもダハトサンユッタといって
ダハトという言葉のコレクションという意味で
じゃあその言葉の意味は
基本的な根本的な性格によって人々が互いに合ってしまう
付き合ってしまう 群がってしまう
馬が合うということ で
それはこの世の中を見ると
あの簡単に見られますし
それだけ説明するとメインテーマから逸れますから
私はこの今日の解釈を据えてテーマに合うようにいたします
で この我々の性格って何ですかと
我々には 人間にも動物にも
どんな生命にも自分の性格というものあるんですね
で それはこの性格といっても
仏教で気になる性格っていうのは
この生まれてからできた性格というよりは
生まれる時も何か性格ついてるんですね
そういう性格なんです
だから基本的な性格なんです
生まれてから我々教育によっていろんな人のしつけを受けて
我々の生き方は当然変えますけど
でも持って生まれた何かまたあるんですね
性格というもの で それを合理的に理解しようと思えば
みんなに経験あるかどうか分かりませんだけど
例えばこの 自分に子供が2人
あるいは3人いるとする場合は
そういう実際にいた方々はちょっと思い出してみてください
その 3人の子供も赤ちゃんの時は全く同じでしたかと
言うとそうじゃないでしょ
赤ちゃんの時も 例えば上の子が赤ちゃんの時はこうで
こうこうでしたけど この子はこうこうですよというちゃんとした性格があるんですね
私もある私の友達の赤ちゃんを見たんだけど
上の子は二人とも女の子でしたけど
小さい時からもうものすごくわがままで
いつでも泣く もう自分言うことを必ず聞けという態度なんですね
母親の言うことは全く聞かない
だからすごい強烈 赤ちゃんの時もものすごい強烈で
そこで母親も父親もかなり疲れたんですね
子供育てることには もう言ったらもう子供何かに欲しくて泣いちゃったら
もうあげない限りはもう絶対泣き止めない
で 疲れて疲れているのに
また 2番目の子供もお腹に入って
その子が生まれたんですね
それで不思議に その子は生まれた時から笑っちゃうんですね
泣かないんです ある日
その家に行って喋っていると
なんかいきなり赤ちゃんの笑い声が聞こえたんですね
は何ですか？と言ったら
あ あの子はもう目が覚めてるでしょうと
だから普通赤ちゃんが目が覚めたら泣いちゃうでしょ
周りに誰がいなかったら
あの女の子はそうじゃなくて
目が覚めたらまた大きい声で笑ったりすると
で それでお母さんが言ったのは
やっぱりその子は大変もう何の問題もなく育ちやすいんだと
でも上の子にはかなり苦労しましたと
ですから その場合は まあ私の個人的な経験でしたからね
自分には子供がないんだからしょうがないんだけど
で やっぱり生まれる時
性格を持って生まれちゃうんですね
それ大きくなっちゃうとね
まあそんなわがままはいけません
ああだこうだと言って
まあなんとかなんとか直めちゃいますけど
やっぱり生まれつき性格持ってくるんです
その性格 このダートというのはエレメンツ
いわゆるものすごい基本的な性格
それでその同じ性格の人々が
この磁石のように同じ性格の人々と群がっちゃうんです
で そこでいくらか人の性格読めるんです
大体人間の性格なんかは分かりにくいなと思っちゃいますけど
まあそういうことでいくらか分かります
で こういうことなの 説明いたしますと
こういうことなんですね
例えば よく怒りっぽい喧嘩っぽい人がいるとすると
そういう人々と仲良くする
で 例えばこの勉強嫌いな人が子供がいると
もう自分のグループのみんな勉強嫌いグループなんですね
いたずらするグループだったらグループのみんないたずら好きなんですね
人をいじめるのは好きなんですね
それでグループ作っちゃうんですね
ですから 我々はこの居心地のいいグループあるんです
どんな人間にも あ あの人
あの人だったらまあ仲間に入れてもいいと
あまり問題ないという風に自分がすごく居心地がいいんですね
ですから いたずらする人は
我々いたずら嫌いな人から見れば嫌な人なんですが
そのいたずら好きな人々の間ではものすごくもう馬が合ってしまっちゃうんです
例えば私はいたずらは嫌いというならば
ものすごいいたずら好きな人と私と仲良くなっちゃったら
もう毎日迷惑ばっかしなんですね
毎日迷惑ばっかしでなんとかいたずらするんだから
自分にしなくたって他の人にでもするんだから
こちらも仲間だから責任持たなくちゃいけないことになっちゃうし
ですから もうこの人と付き合うのは大変だと
というまあ という風にもう本当は仲良くしない方がいいんじゃないかなと思うとこもあるかもしれませんだけど
もし二人ともいたずらいたずら好きだったら
何のことなく仲良くしてしまっちゃう
それで 人の性格をどういうふうに読みますかというと
ある人の性格 我々はわからない
何者かと すごくカッコ決まってるかもしれません
でも その人の仲間をどういう仲間かなと見ると
その仲間の性格 誰か誰かの性格
あ わかる あれならば あ
なるほど この人も同じ性格の人やとそこで判断できるんですね
ですから 一回もいたずらしなかった子がいて
すごい落ち着いておとなしくいるんだと
この子はおとなしい人やとはっきり早く決めないで
その子の周りの子供たち
その子の仲間たちがいたずらよく好きだったら
我々どのふうに判断するかというと
あの子の仲間は本当に良くないんですよと
あの子は本当に落ち着いていい子なのにと思っちゃうでしょ
普通だったら でもそうじゃないんです
あの子はもしかするとあまりにも社会から責めるんだから怖くていたずらしないかもしれません
でも 心の中の性格はいたずらしたいという性格かもしれません
だから あの仲間に入って落ち着いているんですね
ですから 自分にできないんだから
できる人のグループに入っていると
ですから この人間の性格によって
人間が似たものがいつでも一緒になるということはあるんです
それは磁石と同じなんですね
それで あの業の場合はどういうこと関係あるかというと
あの 例えば人間があまり
なんて言いますか 運が悪い人だったら
運が悪い同士です 仲が良くなっちゃうし
すごい運がいい人だったら
運のいい人々はまた一緒のグループになっちゃうし
そういうことはあるんでしょうね
世の中で 例えば 仕事でも何でもきちんとやって
何でも成功する人だったら
仕事のだらしのない人ともう付き合いたくないでしょ
普通だったら だらしのない人
もうあなた方とはもう付き合いたくないと
私まではダメになりますよと言って
自分がまだ仕事をしっかりやっている
しっかりしている人々と仲良くなってしまっちゃうんですね
同じ会社の中でも同じなんですね
グループ作っちゃうと
それはあの大きく見えるグループではないかもしれませんだけど
どこかで心でつながっているんですね
そういうグループ見ると同じ性格
仕事はもうあまりしないでいろいろごまかしするんだったら
その人々はすぐ仲が良くなっちゃうし
地味に仕事する人々はまたそちらに別な仲間を作ってしまっちゃうし
そういうことはごく普通に世の中にある
それは心にある一つの働きなんですね
あまりにも違う性格と会うと
なけなかぶつかり合ってぶつかり合って生活はしにくい
だから生活しやすくために
楽に落ち着いて生活するために
自然に 自分にぴったし合う仲間を作るんです
それ不思議なこと もし皆様方が外国旅行したりする
その中でもすぐ仲間になっちゃうんです
同じ性格の人は 何のことなく
もう言葉もしゃべれないのに
もうなんとなく心が通じ合っちゃうんですね
で あのよくあの飼い主の性格が動物に映りますよという話が日本にあるでしょ
あれはもうそうじゃなくて違うと思います
私は逆だと思いますね
もし飼い主と飼ってるペットがものすごくうまく合ってるというならば
二人とも性格はもともと同じということなんです
それですごく合うんですね
だから性格合わないペットもいくらでもいるでしょうね
犬は飼ったんだけど 毎日犬に文句ばっかり言って
この犬は言うことを聞いてくれない
ああだこうだとかね そういうふうなペットもいるんだから
世の中に まあしょうがない
まあずっと面倒見たんだから面倒見てやるっていう感じで面倒は見てあげるんだけど
ちゃんと散歩に連れて行きたい
行くんだけど まあ義理で
じゃあ散歩という風にもあるし
ものすごいお互いに仲良くしてるペットもいるんですね
それでペットの性格 飼い主の性格をペットに映したというよりは
もうもともとお互いの性格がぴったし合ってる場合はあるんですね
だからまあペットから勉強してもらうことはないんだから
ペット買う時のあの基本というのは
やっぱり自分の性格に合うペット買うことなんです
例えばこの凶暴な犬がいるんですね
みんな飼いたがらないでしょ
でも凶暴な性格の人にはものすごく合うんですね
犬の場合も他の人に凶暴なんですけど
この性格的に凶暴な人の人に対しては
この犬はきちんともう折伏というか
もう言うことをよく聞くんです
何の問題もないんです
座ると言ったら座るし
外行ってくださいと言ったらちゃんと行くし
おいでくださいったら来るし
言うこと聞いてくれる
そこで心がすごい優しい人が買っちゃったら
もう全然合わなくなっちゃうんですね
互いにまるっきり合わない
吠える時はもうやめなさいと言っても全然やめてくれない
さらに怒って なんだあなたっていう感じで吠えちゃうんですね
たまにこの飼い主がこの捕まっていても行って相手を攻撃しようと
飼い主に捕まったらもう攻撃してはいけないということはわかってるんだけど
それでももうとにかく行って相手を攻撃しようとしてる
そういう性格の犬もいるんですね
ですから この世の中を見ると
やっぱりそういうことも言えますから
ペット買う場合はちゃんと自分の性格に合ったペット買った方がすごい育てやすい
で その場合も 動物の中でも
動物と人間の間でも 動物の間でも
この性格の合うものはお互いに居心地がいいんだから
群がってグループを作るということがあるんです
で そういうことでもともと運が悪い人は
もうどうしても運が悪い同士で仲良せちゃうんですね
そこで自分の運が悪いんだから
何とかしたらどうでしょうかと相談するのは
そういう人々相談するんです
この頃うまく商売行きませんだけど
どうすればいいでしょうね
そうですねとか その人
運が悪いんですから で
それでうまくいかないでしょう
倒産した人々は倒産同士で集まるグループ作っちゃうし
だから世の中にいろんな会議やらいろんなものあるでしょうにね
そういう場合も同じものが集まって一つの会で作るでしょう
もう例えばいろいろ金融機関でひどい目にあった人々
被害者の会とかね 同じグループなんですね
そういう会はうまくいくんです
互いにあまり混乱なく
同じ運命だから 戦争の被害者とかね
いろいろいろんな名前で似たものが
同じ目的を持って同じ人生観を持ってる人々は
一つの会やら会社やら会社というのはね
何かシステム 何か作って
そういう何か団体を作るんですね
作って行動しようとする
で それは世の中はそういう風に流れるんですね
だから運命変えるということはもうなかなか難しいんです
被害者の会だったらみんな被害者だから
互いにどうやって助け合うだろうかっていうこと
ね もう自分も被害者で他人も被害者で
だから被害者を助けるためには
被害を受けてない人いた方がいいんですが
そう なかなかね そういう集まりにはならないんですね
例えば被爆者と被爆者でない人々の会と言ったら
誰一人も入らないんです
被爆者の会といったら
さっとその人々はメンバーとして入っちゃうんですね
会社クビになった人々の会といったらみんな入っちゃうし
会社クビになった人々と元気で仕事をしている人々の会といったら一人もメンバーがなくなっちゃうんです
本当は会社クビになった人がものすごい元気で仕事をしてクビになる見込みは全くない
人と付き合うとなんとかうまくいくと思いますけどね
その人から何か勉強して
どうやればうまく仕事できるんですか？どうやれば雇い主に気に入られるかと
その人からそのいろいろ方法を教えてもらった方がいいんですが
そうはいかないんですね
世の中では そういうことで
我々の運命というか 業というのはまあ決まってるパターンで流れるようになってるんです
それは変更できますけど
これきついんですね 変更っていうのは難しくなってるんですね
人間の性格の問題があるんだから
そこで好きというか このラッキーというかアンラッキーというか
そういうところで話に戻りますが
あのお釈迦様の教から申し上げると
例えば怒りっぽい人々が怒りっぽい人々で集まりますと
欲張りの人々は欲張りの人々で集まっちゃうんだと
怠ける人々は怠け同士で集まるんだと
無知な人々は無知同士で集まっちゃうんだと
それでまあ不幸はそのまま続けていっちゃうんですね
それで知恵の人がすぐ知恵の人々と仲良くしちゃう
成功する人々は成功する人々となかよししちゃう
欲がない人々がまた欲がない人々と仲良くしてしまっちゃう
そうすると いい性格の人々だったら
どんどんいい方向へ行ってしまっちゃうんですね
そのわけで 世の中でラッキーな人がどう何があろうともラッキーでしょう
アンラッキーな人はもうもう何をしてあげたってもアンラッキーになっちゃうんですね
なんか助けてあげたっても
もうまたダメになってしまっちゃう
ということがあるんです
ですから このカルマですか
業のことを理解すると
それよく覚えておいてください
で たまに例えばお金の使い方があまり上手でない人々いるんですね
お金入ったら使ってしまっちゃう
計画性はない またお金入るか入らないかそれも気にしない
とにかく入ったものはすぐ使おうと
で それでお金がなくなっちゃうでしょうに
なくなってひどく困っちゃうと
誰かがじゃああなたにも何か助けてあげようと思って助けてあげたら
あ ありがとうございますってすぐそれ使ってしまっちゃうんです
また同じ運命なんです
私もそういう友達が一人いるんですね
何の計画性もない お金が入ったらすぐもう使ってしまいます
それで お金が何もないんだと
もっと悩んだりする はい
わかりましたと言ってあげちゃったら
例えば私だったら 1ヶ月間使うお金かもしれませんだけど
この人 2日目で終わったと
何のことなく言うんです
ああいうもの ああいうことして
まあちょっとどこか行ったんだと
それでまあちょっと疲れたんだから
まあ車借りたところで
まあ車の人がこれぐらいお金取ったんだと
歩けばいい その場合はね
まあ歩けばいいんだけど
やっぱりそういうことをやってしまっちゃうんですね
目の前に置きましょう
動くのは大体右手だから
そういうふうな性格 皆様も自分の周りの人々を見ると大体もうお分かりと思います
そんなに難しいことじゃないんですね
で だから何とかしたければ
我々は自分の性格をもうよく改善してくれる
自分の弱みを何とかして直してくれる人と付き合った方がいいんだけど
その付き合い方はそれほどスムーズじゃないんです
性格違いますから スムーズじゃないんです
すごく苦労しなくちゃいけない
自分もすごく否定して追い出されるかもしれませんが
あんたもういいですよ
あっち行きなさいとかね
それでも自分がもうしつこく
この人は大変できてる人だから
いくら追い出されても自分の方で行って
その人についてなんとか自分の性格を直そうというふうな
この本人の努力は必要なんです
ああ 来てくださいというのは同じ性格の人なんですね
ですから この我々の まあ運命というかね
いい方向へ持っていきたい場合は
まあちょっとまあちょっと険しいというかね
その道がね ちょっと難しいということもあるんですね
ですから なかなか人間簡単に運命変えるということはね
簡単ではなくなっているんです
変えることは変えられます
あの法則的には変えられますが
いわゆる生まれつき定めだから
運命だから あんたは不幸だというふうに言うことはないんです
変えれば変えられます
全て無常だから でもそれはなかなか我々の習性というか
生まれつきついてくるこの性格によってそうはいかないんですね
その性格の問題というのはどれほど巨大かというと
例えば仏教のね 出家して修行して悟り開いた人がいるとします
いわゆる完全に悟りましたと
するとお釈迦様と同じ
もう完璧に悟った人なの
そういう時でも 自分の性格と合う人々と付き合うんだと
やっぱり生活しやすいんですね
すごくスムーズにいきますから
自分が悟っていて 煩悩も何もないんだから
まあみんなと他の人々にも仲良くして
まあ教えてあげたり 指導したり
じゃあ頑張ろうではないかというところはもう大変きついんです
その悟った人にとっても
ブッダにとっても同じことなんです
面倒見るのは大変ややこしくてきついんです
疲れるんですね そこでこのお釈迦様
ある日 この同じお経のセットの中なんですけど
あのお坊さんたちも一応仲間作ってグループ作って
もう生活しているんです
いろんなグループグループ作って
そこでお釈迦様のそばにいつでもいたのはアナンダ尊者というお釈迦様の義理の兄弟なんですね
義理の弟 あの日本語でアナンダと読んでパーリ語でアーナンダと言うんですけどね
で すごく記憶力 記憶力は抜群で
お釈迦様が話すことは何でも 1回で暗記してしまう
覚えておく ですから お釈迦様にとっては歩いている図書館
生きてる図書館なんですね
で 他の誰が質問したら
その質問にお釈迦様は前喋ったことで答えられるならば
アナンダ尊者がそれを教えてあげる
こういうことで こういう日でお釈迦様はこういうこういうことを言いましたと
全く同じ言葉でそのまま繰り返して言うんですね
それでお釈迦様にとって大変便利でしたけど
お経は覚えていると それで
ある日 お釈迦様がこのアナンダ尊者見えるでしょうとね
そちらのアナンダ尊者の中にたくさんグループがいるんですね
あのグループの人々みんな同じよくお経を覚えているんだと
よくいわゆる暗記力を随分抜群に優れている人々だと
そこで あのウパーリ尊者というまたもう一人
偉大阿羅漢がいたんですね
ウパーリ尊者のところも
ものすごい何百人もお坊さんたちがいつでもいるんです
どこへ行っても大勢のお坊さんたちが一緒に行ったり来たり
そこでそのウパーリ尊者っていうのは戒律のすごい専門家なんです
そこであちらにいるお坊さんたちはみんな戒律に対してはすごい詳しいんだと
だからそこ性格として合うんですね
戒律勉強するとなんとか法律勉強することと大体似ていましたから
そういう性格の人々は
じゃあお経は置いといて
我々は戒律のことを専門でやろうではないかと
まあ修行しながらそういうことをなさっている
それでサーリプッタ尊者の仲間はみんなものすごい智慧があった人々で
鋭い知識があった人々で
モクレン尊者のグループはみんないろんな神通力やらいろんな超能力やら
瞑想の達人たちで だからそういうお釈迦様の同じ弟子の中でも
そういうふうにグループできちゃったんですね
できて 自分に合う性格
話し合うできる人々は一緒になっちゃう
例えば瞑想のいろんな人間に分からない高いレベルのことやら
超能力のことやら ああだこうだ喋っちゃうと
モクレン尊者はそこのプロで専門家で
だから話し合えるんですね
この場合はどうすればどうすればいいんでしょうか
先生と聞いたら この場合はこうしなさいとか教えてくれるし
そこで戒律のお坊さんに聞いたっても分かりませんだから
合わなくなっちゃうんですね
で それはですから このいい性格の性格できた人々
悟った方々の場合も この問題は同じなんです
似ているものは一緒にあってしまっちゃう
で 悟った方々には別に問題ないんだけど
一般の方々は自分の人生はね
よりいい方向へ持ちたいと思うならば
自分の性格にぴったし合う人を探すんじゃなくて
自分の欠点よく理解して
それの反対の人々と付き合った方がいいと思いますけどね
例えばどうしても怠け癖ついてる人は
ものすごいしっかく頑張ってる人と仲良くすると
そうすると向こう側に嫌ですからね
この人怠け者で もう朝早く起きないとかことありますから
ですから蹴っ飛ばしでも起こしちゃうんですね
早く起きなさい 何やってるんですかと
それでその人に従えば
どんどん自分の性格を直して怠け癖を直っちゃうんです
頭は悪い人 鈍い人が やっぱり頭は鋭い人と付き合った方がいいんですね
でも 頭が鋭い人にとっては
それすごい迷惑なんですね
話し相手にもならないし
言うことは理解しないし
で 迷惑なんですけど この性格の弱い人は
それでも一生懸命その人に付いていくと
いくら批判されても いくら嫌なされても気にしないでもう付いていくと
どんどん鋭くはなるんですね
ですから この まあそういうのは大体子供たちにとってはとってもいいことなんですね
子供たち育てるためには
このすごい難しい工夫するよりは
なんかいい仲間を作ってあげれば
確実に性格を直せちゃうんですね
ですから この子供はすごく早く性格乗り移っちゃいますからね
人のこと ですから 一番いいことっていうのは
そういういい仲間を作ってあげること
それはこの心の磁石の法則なんですね
同じものは似ているものは引いてしまっちゃうんだと
だからもともと暗い人はもう暗い人と一緒になってさらに暗くなる
凶暴な人はまた他の凶暴な仲間作っちゃって
さらに凶暴になって犯罪まで起こしちゃって
もう人生はもう台無しにしてしまっちゃう
それはこの 何て言いますか
すぐにこの好きから見放される人々はそういう人々なんですね
別に好きから見放されたということというよりは
自分の性格の問題なんですね
ですから それは仏教の合論でかなり合理的だと思いますけどね
ですから 運命 定めという言葉は仏教ではない
使ってはいけない言葉なんです
英語で言えばFateと言うんですね
これ英語の言葉で これ運命という意味なんですね
合論は語るんだけど Fate
ではないんですと 運命では宿命ではないんだと
まあなんかややこしいんですけどね
まあいわゆる変わらないわけじゃない
努力すれば変わるんです
人の運命が でも世の中の生き方を見ると
すぐ我々の頭にこれは宿命やと言ってしまっちゃうでしょうに
それも無理がないんですね
なぜならば 我々はこの似た者同士で生活しているんだから
どんどんもうひどくなる一方か良くなる一方か
どっちかなんですね  あまり大事な例じゃないんだけど
例えばものすごく立派に仕事をして
仕事を成功して ある人はものすごく豊かになるんだと
このなった人が何とかの関係で全部財産なくなってしまったとします
でもその人はまた立ち直るでしょ
例えば いくら豊かになっても
国の経済状態悪くなっちゃったら
世界の状態が何かなったら
あるいは地震なんか起きちゃったら
全財産なくなる可能性ありますよ
それは運命とは言わない
自分で何の努力 何のすることもできませんだから
自然なことだから それで全財産なくなっても
自分が生まれた時もお金がなくて生まれて
それでもきちんと頑張って仕事をして
ちゃんと行動して成功した人であるならば
また一からやり直しちゃうんです
泣かない そういうのは世の中を見ると
そういうケースというのは一般的にごく普通にあるんですね
それなぜでしょうかと言えば
まあその人はもうそういう性格だから
そのきちんと頑張る人々といっしょになって
ちゃんと考えて行動してしまっちゃうんです
ですから 幸福な人はもう大体もう幸福でいてしまっちゃうんです
不幸な人は不幸でいてしまっちゃうんです
それであまり知恵のない人々は
その現実を見て あの人好いてるんだ
あの人は好いてないんだ
それは運命だ それは定めだ
それは宿命だと どうしようもないんだと
お手上げだと決めたくなっちゃいますけど
仏教はそうは言わない
そうじゃなくて その人々の生き方として
似て似た者同士 似た者同士で繋がりますから
同じ結果になるだけで
ほんのちょっと工夫しちゃえば
そのサイクルが変えちゃうんですね
だからどんな不幸な人にも
ほんのちょっと工夫しちゃえば
その不幸のサイクルが幸福のサイクルに入れ替えることはできるんです
インドではある宗教があって
この宗教名前を言っても構いませんだけど
ジャイナ教なんですね
ジャイナ教 英語でジャイニズムと書くんですけど
今もその宗教はあります
ジャイナ教なんですね
まあジャイナ教という
まああの それ批判するために言うんじゃなくて
結構立派な宗教なんですけど
で そのジャイナ教の教祖様がすごいこのカルマのことを教えていたんですね
だからカルマにカルマのことは一番強烈に教えたのはジャイナ教なんです
仏教じゃないんです 仏教はカルマ論に心理学を導入して心理学で分析しちゃったんです
ジャイナ教はカルマ論を物理学で説明したんです
それで あの あまり深く読まないで
表だけを経典だけ読んじゃうと似てるんじゃないかとみんな思うかもしれません
それほど言ってることは似てるんです
でも基本的にはジャイナ教は物理学の説明を使っているんです
すごい合理的に説明してますけど
お釈迦様はそれは全部捨てて
完全たる心理学でカルマのことを説明しているんです
それで あの お互いに話し合う場合は
お釈迦様はもういとも簡単に相手をもう間違っているということは言っていたんだけどね
互いに話し合った時はね
それでこのジャイナ教は物理学的に説明しているんだから
このフェイト カルマはもうフェイト決まっていて
フェータリズム これは英語でフェータリズムという言葉があります
辞書を引いてみてください
という教えを教えちゃったんですね
いわゆる定め 運命論 宿命論というものを教えちゃったんですね
で 彼が物理的な物理的な説明だから
人間の体の構造はもう決まってるんだから
何の変化もできないんだと
で その彼らの教えは 現代的な医学の知識でもう一度通訳してみると
例えば我々は人間として形を作る瞬間でもう DNA のプログラム
あのね できちゃうでしょうに
あの染色体できちゃいますから
母親の半分と父親の半分が持って一緒になるんだけど
その中でもどういうどういう DNA の組み合わせ方もできちゃうんですね
それでもう体の構造は死ぬまで決まってるんです
何歳で病気になるか もう全部もう決まっちゃうんですね
がんになるんだったら
もうちゃんとその年になるともうがんになるとかね
ですから 今はね がんになる DNA やら糖尿病になる DNA やら
そういういろいろ見つかってるし
で 一般的には我々の DNA 構造は変えられないでしょう
それは細胞変えなきゃいけませんだから
細胞変えることはできませんだから
骨の細胞まで変えられちゃったら
もうその人は全くもう亡くなっちゃうし
別人になっちゃうし 変えられませんと
それは物理的な説明 ですから
物理的な説明取ると 業は絶対的であって変えられません
例えば大体世の中で我々軽々くこういうですね
神様にそう決められたんだからとかね
大体何か不幸に遭っちゃうとすぐそう言ってしまっちゃうんですね
まあ神様に決められたものだから
まあしょうがないと で
そういう時も同じフェータリズムなんですね
我々の運命はもう最初からもうプログラムを組んでおいてるんだと
ですから その組まれたプログラムによって生きるしか何もないんだと
で その業論は仏教では邪教だと
間違っているんだと 邪見だと否定するんです
物理的な説明はもう良くないんだと
その物理的な法則は 仏教では違う法則に入れているんです
それはこの種子の種の法則という言葉がありまして
で それでまあそういう法則ですよと
種はもうその植物の形やら全部もう決まってるんだから
人間も種から出てくるもんだから
まあ一応まあそれは体のシステムで
それはもう別に変えても変えなくたっても別にどうったことはない
問題は生命だから心を持っていること
幸福か不幸かっていうのは心の問題であると
足が 1本なくなったら不幸だと決められませんね
足が 1本なくても その日はその人が明るく元気で堂々と頑張っているならば
別にそれは全然損にはならないんですね
心の問題なんですね 足が 1本なくなっても
ものすごい元気で明るく頑張っている人がいて
ちょっとした怪我しただけでものすごい落ち込んじゃっても大変損する人もいるんですね
それはもう物質の問題ではなくて
心の問題ですと ですから
仏教では人の色によって幸福やとは言わない
明るい色で生まれたら不幸だ
幸福ですよとは言わない
美しく生まれたんだからと言って
そういうのはあまり業論にはあんまり使わない
使う時もありますけどね
それよりは心の持ち方で幸福か不幸かと決められるんだと
心っていうのはまあそれほど苦労しなくても変えられます
体変えることはまあそれほど簡単ではないんですね
我々の色を変えることも
背が高くないんだと思ったら
随分高い背が高くする
それはできないしね それはまあそれほどできない
でも心を明るくするかしないかということは簡単にできる
そこら辺を理解していないんだから
みんなすぐあ 業だ 運命だ
宿命だ どうしようもないんだと諦める
それからなんでそうなるかというと
今前も説明したように
ダート層はこの根本的な性格によって我々はお互いに付き合っているんだからと
ですからもう一つ 自分が人生は成功するかしないかと
若いうちで自分で判断できるんです
それは仏教の知識がある人だけなんですけどね
小さい時からもその教えをね
教えてあげたら 子供でもわかるんです
自分の仲間は自分がどんな仲間と一緒にいると気に入るかと言ったら
もう将来は見えたもんなんですね
で 自分がこの小学生の時なんかはね
まあその時は別にみんなあまり学生の間では差がない年ですからね
小さい小さいんだからみんなと仲良くしてるんですね
自分がその時でもあまり真剣に勉強しない子供たち見ると
なんとなくどこかでちょっともう他の机に行こうかなという感じが出てくるんですね
で 一緒に遊ぼうとか何とか言って
もうよくいろんなことを喋ったりする
それで先生来て教えてるんですけど
それに構わず喋ったりすると
僕はすごくもうこれ嫌だし
この人喋るの全然面白くないんだと
一回覚えてるんですね
クラスでこの後に座ることになっちゃって
それとはそこにいた生徒たちがすごい仲良くして
すごい仲間に入れてくれたんだけど
この連中は喋るは喋るは
遊ぶは遊ぶはもう授業があるかないか
そうこう全く無関心で
で 僕は 1日目見て終わったら
これ大変だと これだったら自分がすごいひどい目に遭いますと
この小さい割に思ったんですね
なんとかして一番前に座らなきゃダメだと言って
次の日からとにかく先生の機嫌を取るんです
いろんなことを工夫して
まあ子供は誰でもやってることが別に大したことないんだけどね
機嫌を取って 先生 私はこっち座ってもいいんですか？と言うと
いいですよと言われたら
もうまあ それで そうでないと大変なことになるんですね
だから この性格的に 自分の性格としては
やっぱり言うことをちゃんと聞くもんだと
人いうことをちゃんと頑張って理解するもんだという性格
生まれつきついてたんだから合わなかったんですね
で それで母親がもし子供たちにね
その論理を教えてあげるならば
それまた嘘でもないし
事実ですからね お化けの話やらね
もうもうハリセンボン
なんとかなんとかって
そんなことなくてね そういう事実だけ教えてあげると
子供たちが自分で自分を観察しちゃうんですね
自分のこと見えませんから
将来のことだから 自分がどんな仲間がいるかで
仲間のこと見るとすぐ分かってしまっちゃうし
それで気をつけて違う仲間作ればもう問題ないんですね
だからどういう そういう風に我々の将来をいくらかはこの占うことはできるんです
それはもう 90%以上当たるんです
仲間を見て その人のことを判断すると
私はずっとそういうデータをね
頭で集めたんだからね
ほとんど合いましたから
で 学校にしても 大学で教えている時でも
やっぱり生徒たちの性格を見て
どんな仲間かなと見たら
もう将来はもう見えたもんですね
後で見ると全くその通りでしたから
変わらなかったんだから
やっぱりそれはすごい気をつけた方がいいことで
そこは気をつけちゃうと
我々はちゃんと好きを呼ぶ人になるんですね
我々努力して幸福な生活をすることは
もうとても簡単にできるんです
でも簡単ですけど もう道がね
ちょっと砂利道なんですね
絨毯敷いてないんです
それだけを なぜならば
自分に合わない性格の人と付き合わなくちゃいけないんだから
ですから 例えば結婚する時でも
性格が合うか合わないかということは
まあよく気にするでしょうし
インド文化だったら結婚する前にきちんと占ってもらうんです
星座は全部読んで もう計算して計算して
24種類かな  27種類の計算して
27種類の尺度から その二人の性格を見るんですね
見て もう半分以上合うと結婚してもいいというんです
半分以下だったらやめた方がいいと
いくら小さい時からお互い仲良くしていたっても
これはちょっとあなた方二人合わないんだと言ったりする
占い信じてる人とか それ信じて諦め諦めちゃいますけどね
で でも占い師もそう言う
でもあなた方 それよく理解して一緒になるならば
別に問題ない その二十七の二十七項目はね
まあもう七つしか合わないとかね
それでも一緒になりたいというならば
それを理解して一緒になってくださいとと言うんだから
それで二人で努力しちゃうとうまくいくんですね
占いで合わないんだからって言って
必ずしも不幸な家族になるということまたないんですね
別に私は占いを正当化しているわけじゃないんで
私は別に占い信じてないし
一応そういう文化的にも
そういう結婚する時は合う性格の二人が結婚できたら
何の問題もなく もうスムーズに人生は生きますけど
問題はその時は欲張り屋の女の人とまた欲張り屋の男が一緒になっちゃう
で ぴったし合うんですよ
馬が でも人生はまああまり明るくはならない
怒りっぽい攻撃的な二人が一緒になっちゃうと
もう二人で組んでもう社会に攻撃して生活しちゃいますけど
で 幸福になるかどうかがまた別なんですね
ですから すぐ怒る人と全く怒らない落ち着いてる人と一緒になっちゃったら
もしかするとうまくいくかもしれません
でも努力しなきゃ その場合は
すごい努力必要なんです
ですから 最初はもうお互いにこの人はいつでも落ち着いて何ですかってのかなというふうに
例えば奥さんが凶暴な性格だったら
もう何でも喧嘩売ってしまっちゃう
旦那が落ち着いてるならば
もう別にもう何のこと知らんふりしていると
で 奥さんが旦那に対して怒っちゃうんですね
なんであんたそんな時何も言わなかったんですかと
ああだこうだとか でも互いにお互いの性格を理解して言っちゃうといいところまで行っちゃうんですね
例えば旦那さんがあまりものんびり屋さんで
問題は真剣に考えないならば
やっぱり自分ももうちょっと行動的でいろいろ問題は真剣に考えた方がいいんじゃないかと
自分がいくらか直せちゃうし
奥さんもいつでも凶暴で叩くんじゃもう喧嘩するんじゃなくて
もうちょっと落ち着いた方がいいんじゃないかなと
お互いの性格で合わせちゃうと
いい方向へは行っちゃうんですね
ですから この結婚の場合でもね
必ずしも合う性格の二人結婚する必要でまたないんですね
合わない場合はきちんと理解して
どちらの性格が悪いかを見て悪い方が直す直せばいいんですね
そういうことで難しいということだけ申し上げたいんですね
じゅうたん引いてないんだと
幸福の道には ずいぶん砂利道だと
裸足で歩かなくちゃいけないんだとことだけ覚えておいてください
それでも一つのポイントは終わりました
この好きを呼ぶ人と好きから見放される人
見放される人ということで
次のポイントは同じ磁石論なんですけど
あの同じ極がもう何て言いますか
引き離しちゃうんですね
磁石の場合は 鉄には付けますけど
磁石は例えばS極とS極せなけたらもうすぐもう追い出しちゃう
心はもう磁石だから またその法則を持ってるんです
それで人間が幸福になる
不幸になるということは
そこでまた働くんですね
それはちょっと説明は難しいと思いますけど
それはこういうこと で
どこかで私は何回も同じ話を申し上げましたけどね
例えばものすごい欲張る人がいるんですね
で 欲張る人の心のエネルギーはどういうエネルギーかというと
自分には何もないと思っちゃうんですね
無意識的に 自分の心も貧しいです
元々 私にはもう何もないという状態でいて
だから外のものを見て
あれも欲しい これも欲しい
あれもやらなくちゃ これもやらなくちゃと
と必死になって行動する
そうすると その人成功するだろうと思うでしょ？なぜならば
もう自分何もないんだからという貧しい心を持ってるんだから
一生懸命頑張って仕事して
あるいはいろんなことをして
いろんな能力やら才能やら
まあもう財産やら集まるんだからね
まあ一生懸命頑張っちゃうといくらかは集まる可能性はあるんだけど
でもその人いうとずっと暗いんですね
心は だから欲張りの人がいくら財産があっても暗いんです
欲張りだから そこでその人から出てくるエネルギーっていうのは
外のものは自分の方向へ強引に引っ張るというエネルギーなんですね
こちら空っぽだからね
いつでもこちらで心で枠を持ってるんだからね
吸しちゃうんで 掃除機と同じですけど
で それでその人と世の中付き合ってみようとしちゃうと
世の中は何を感じるかというと
この人が自分を引っ張ろうと自分から取ろうとしているのではないか
と思う 感じるんですね
で じゃあ逃げようと ですから
もう逃げる気持ち生まれちゃうんですね
じゃあ例を言います ここここにすごいかわいい猫がいるとします
そうすると誰でもああ
かわいいですねとすぐ触りたくなるでしょう
そこで左側に可愛い猫を置いておいて
右側にライオンを置いとくと
みんな我々の気持ちどうですか
ライオンの方からものすごく逃げよう逃げようと檻に入れておきなさいと鎖でも縛っておきなさいと言うかもしれません
それでも怖く怖く猫の方に行くんでしょう
だから猫は友達を呼ぶ
ライオンが友達を追い出す
ライオンどんなエネルギーを持ってるかでも
別にライオンはいつでも人を食うわけじゃないんだけど
我々の例だからね 我々の感じから見れば
ライオン触ったら食べられるかもしれませんとね
食われるかもしれませんと
自分を吸収されるかもしれませんというエネルギーでしょ
じゃあライオンそういうエネルギー出してるんだからライオンは怖がっちゃう
猫はそういうエネルギーではないんですね
この人に可愛がってもらおうと言って
自分から可愛らしさを出してるんですね
そうすると引っ張られちゃうんです
そういうことで理解しておきましょう
で 欲張りな心を持ってる人が向こう側
宇宙から世界からはものを取ろうとしてるんですね
それで世界が危ないと囚われるんだと
気をつけろという風に
一つの安全壁を作っちゃうんです
安全な壁を作ったら この人にはそのほど簡単には取れないんです
だから動物の世界と同じ
もうライオンでも狩りに行っても
そんな簡単には狩りはできません
みんな逃げるんです そこで死にかけている動物とか
足が折れている動物とか
病気の動物とか は取れますけど
それで取って食べて まあ 1週間食べたということになりますけどね
元気のいい獲物は 1匹も取れませんね
ライオンには まあ虎でも同じことですけども
元気な連中は逃げてしまう
それでいつでも病気な動物しか食べることができなくなっちゃうんです
で 人間の場合も 欲張りな人にはそういうふうに
まああの付き合う時はみんなそういう欠陥だらけの人々しか付き合うことができなくなる
社会からすごく犬猿と犬
何て言いますか 敬遠されるという
まあそんな難しいことじゃないんで
私達も嫌いでしょう 欲張りな人っていうのは
全然もう人に接待もしないし
あの家に呼んでご飯でも食べようとか
そういうこともしないし
とにかくお金ばっかり計算して
自分がどれぐらい儲かるかって
そればっかり考えちゃう人は
なんかすごい嫌な人という感じがするでしょうね
その人とはもう付き合わない方がいいんだと
お金の話ばっかりだと
そうなるんです いわゆる分かりやすく言えば
自分の財布はきちーんと逃げることになっちゃうんです
だから ある人が欲張りになったら
世の中がみんな自分の財布をきちんと閉めると
と この人どうなるんですか？不幸なままで終わっちゃうんです
ですから お釈迦様はそれを簡単にこう言うんです
欲張りの行為をする人が貧しく生まれるんだと
そういうふうに言った方が分かりやすいでしょ
欲深い人が貧しく生まれるんだと
で 欲深いということも本来貧しいということであるし
心が貧しい 別に財産的に貧しいということじゃない
これは心の問題 仏教はいつでも心の問題で言ってますから
物理的にではないんです
大金持ちでも欲張りはいるし
お金がない人も欲張りがいるし
ですから それお金の問題ではない
財産の問題ではない 心の問題
だから心は欲張りの心だったら本来貧しい
その人はもうそれからの貧しい回転をしてしまっちゃう
で 生まれつきまた性格決まってるんだから
生まれつきもう不幸な人いるんですね
必要なものは手に入らないし
もういろいろ 例えばいい学校に入ろうと思ったっても
もうちょっと 1時間遅くなって
もう全部もう終わりという風になっちゃうし
学校に行ったっていい学校に入ってくれないとかね
いい大学に入るしたら
ちょっと 2点ぐらいなくなくて
もうそこはできなかったとかね
滑って他のところに行かなくちゃいけなかったとか １
回仕事を探す時でもいい仕事あったのに
ほんのちょっとわずかなことで
それちょっともうミスをして
もう入らなくなったりとかね
そういう人生をずっとそういう人生になって終わっちゃうんですね
それはもう生まれる前からもこの
そういうエネルギーを持って生まれちゃうんです
欲張りのエネルギー 欲張りと言ったよりは
この自分に何もない なんか取らなくちゃという
なんか取らなくちゃというエネルギー
それでまたお釈迦様のもっと分かりやすい
もう一つ言葉あるんですね
泥棒する人が どこどこではなくて
生まれ変わるたびにものすごい貧しいところで生まれ変わるんだよという分かりやすい言葉がございます
人のものを取ったら貧しくなるんだと
それ悪いカルマなんですけど
だから泥棒するなと 同じ法則なんですね
泥棒したっていうことは
人のものを取ったっていうことなんですね
不法的に 人のものをなぜ取ったかというと
自分にはないということでしょう
心の中 だから欲張りのエネルギーは同じエネルギーなんですね
そういう取ろう取ろうというエネルギー持っていっちゃうと
社会がもう逃げろ逃げろというエネルギーを作っちゃうんです
ですから そういう人から財産逃げるんです
財産逃げるって言ったら
財産に足があるわけじゃないんです
お金に足がないでしょうに
ですから どうやって財産逃げますかというと
財産というのはやっぱり人間なんです
人間と一緒に財産が入るんですよ
例えば 私はまるっきり一人で
もう何万平方も土地を持って一生懸命農業やってるんだと
お金になりますか？あれは
全然なりません 人がいるとそれお金になるんです
人が来てそれ買ってくれると
それは財産になっちゃうんですから
財産というのはやっぱり人間通して入るもんなんです
もう自分の庭掘った もうちょっとゴミを埋めようと穴掘ったところで
そこで大きいダイヤの何て言いますか
入ってる なんとか出ますね
あれ なんて言います 鉱山
宝石ってあのダイヤなんか出てくるのは掘ったら出てくるでしょ
銀とか金とか何でも鉱山っていうんですか？何て言うんですか
鉱山 自分が庭でちょっと穴掘ったらダイヤの鉱山見つかったんだと
でもそれは大変 財産になるなるならば人がいる時だけなんです
まるっきり人がいなかったら
あれ食べられませんし
何の役にも立たない ただの石だけなんですね
その場合は でも 自分が社会の中に生きているんだから
他の人々と色んな関係を持ってるんだから
もしダイヤが見つかったら
それ大変お金になっちゃうんです
ですから この財産というのは一度覚えておいてください
人間の体に乗ってくるものなんです
油田が見つかったって同じことなんです
自分の家 庭に油田があったっても
人間がいなかったら あれは 1円にもならない
それよりは迷惑なんです
綺麗な水がないんだから
そこら辺に あの面白い話
歴史なんですけど 南アメリカにね
このもうヨーロッパ人がね
まあ行ってアメリカを取っちゃったんだけど
それでアメリカにいた原住民の方々がもう油田の上
上まで出ていたんですね
でもその人たちにとって
それ財産ではなかったんです
ただ 筋肉痛とかね 体が疲れたらそちらにちょっと油を取って
体に塗って もう薬として使ったりして
ですから それ大変神様のところだから
誰も入るのは大事に守っていたんですけど
それ白人たちがいて その人々みんな殺しちゃって
追い出しちゃって それですごい財産になったんだから
アメリカのネイティブアメリカンの場合は
あれ 1ドルにもならなかったんですね
なぜならば そういう人間関係なかったんだから
でもアングロサクソンアングロサクソンの人々にとっては
それは財産になってしまったんです
ですから 土の中で 地球の中でいくらでも財産があると言ったっても
それはちょっと違うし
そこに人間が入ると財産になるということなんですね
そういうことで 人が欲張りで人のものを盗んだりしたら
過去世で で 今世になったところで
やっぱりその人は嫌になるんですね
だから人間がその人から逃げちゃうんですね
人間が逃げちゃうと もう財産も逃げたことになってしまうんです
で 貧しくなってしまうんです
それで法則決まっててね
豊かになりたければ施しをしなさいと
分けて分け合って 自分持っているものをみんなと仲良く分けて
みんなでそれを使いましょうと
来てくださいという言葉はよく使いなさいと
みんなで食べましょうと
みんなで楽しみましょうと
あなたもいかがですかと
そういう心は人を呼ぶ
人を呼ぶということは
幸福も呼ぶということなんです
猫と同じ 猫は人を 呼ぶんだから
ライオンは大きいんだけど
人を追い出しちゃう ところが動物も逃げちゃう
で それはまた同じく まあもう自分から逃げる法則
でも磁石で言ったっても
そこら辺ちょっと説明はちょっと難しい
心の働きだから深いところで説明しないと理解できない
一般的にはだいたい仏教で言いますね
ものを施す人は幸福になりますよと言っても
そうかなと 人にものをあげちゃったらなくなるだけではないかと
自分持ってるものを人にあげちゃったらなくなるだけでしょうと
というふうに一般には人が思うかもしれませんだけどね
1万円あったところで
それ2人使おうと自分には5000円しかないし
一人使っちゃったら自分で 1万円も使えるんではないかと
そう思うのはすごい甘い考え方で
全く表しか見てない そこに裏にあるのは
この 1万円私だけ使ってやるぞという
人にあげませんという気持ちなんですね
人は追い出す 追い払う気持ちなんですね
入ったら迷惑やと で それで当然その人は人を追い払ってるんだから
呼ぶんじゃなくて引き離してるんだから
もう不幸になるしか方法ないんです
それでまたもう一つ分かりやすいことなんですけど
じゃあ経典をちょっと見て説明します
このお釈迦様はこのある若いバラモンがお釈迦様にこう聞くんですね
で コーノコーボーゴータマヘートコーパッチャヨーレーナマヌッサナンゲーワサッタンマヌッサブータナンディッサティヒーナッパニータタ
尊師 なぜこの人間なのにみんな人間同士なのに
人間の中で随分この区別差別見えますかと
差別じゃない区別見えますかと
上下関係 ディッサンティボーゴータマヌッサアッパユカ
寿命は短い人がいるんだと
寿命はすごい長い人がいるんだと
ものすごい病弱の人々がいるんだと
それからすごい健康的な人々がいるんだと
それからすごい醜い人々がいるんだと
それでまたすごい美しい人々がいるんだと
それですごいこのカリスマ的で
このなんかリーダーシップって
なんか人を呼び寄せるぐらいのすごいこの
何て言いますか あれは
なんかそういうカリスマみたいなエネルギーを持ってる人々いるんだと
それからまた何のことなく
みんなにあんまり気にしない
ただそこら辺に人がいるというような感じで
そういうあまり力ない人々もいるんだと
それからすごい豊かな人がいて
豊かでない人々がいるんだと
それからインドの世界だから
この格があるんですね
高い 高いカースト格の人と
ものすごい低いと認められるカーストの人々は
仏教では格は否定していますけど
社会で格を決めちゃったら
低い格に生まれるのはすごい不幸でしょうね
その社会では追い出されますから
そこでものすごい高いカーストに生まれる人がいて
すごい低いカーストに生まれる人がいるんだと
それで智慧がある人がいて
智慧がない人がいるんだと
これ一体全体何なのかと
お釈迦様にこの人を聞いたんですね
言ったらお釈迦様はそれはカルマだよと
業だよ 簡単に答えるんです
人の財産はカルマだと
人はカルマを業を相続しているんだと
業でできているんだと
言ったら この人はお釈迦様
こんな業だよと言ったって分からないんだと
そんな一言で説明したっても
ですから私に詳しく説明してくださいと
分かりやすく お釈迦様が分かりやすく説明するならば
私はそれを理解できるだろうと
だからこのそれも一つのいいことなんですね
わからないものは正直にわからないと言わないと
もう知らないまんまでいっちゃうんですね
それも一つのこちらのあの排他的なことなんですけど
人がすごく高慢で威張ってるでしょ
プライド持って プライド持ってるっていうのはもう自分はもうプライドっていうものがあって
もう他のものは入れないんですね
自分が偉いということで
チェカヨルナーと そういうプライド持ってる人には勉強できないんです
頭悪くなっちゃうんです
例えば勉強しようと思って何か言ったことがわからなかったら
それ聞くのは恥ずかしいんだと
聞いちゃったら 私はわからなかったことをみんなにバレちゃうんだとかね
あるいは自分がプライド持ってるんだからよくわかったような顔をしてる
あの私結構昔ね そういうのも教えていたんだから
もうそれは経験あること
本当にもうよく真面目に聞いてるふりをしてるんですね
この子供たちが それで丁寧にものすごくメモを書いたりとかね
でもこちらはもう知ってるんです
この子は全然わかってないんだと
そこであの あんたわかりましたかというとはいはい
わかりました わかってないんですね
はいはい わかりましたら
またもう一度説明しますと
こちらでもできないでしょうに
だから本当にかわいそうでかわいそうで
もうどうしようもないんですね
ですから わかったかわからなかったって
それたまにいるんです
もうあまりメモも書かない
あっち見たりこっち見たり
足をもう一生懸命足をなんて振ったり
いろんなことをして それでこいつは本当に聞いてないよという感じで
いきなり先生何ですかあれ何ですかと聞くんですね
で 自分がいろんなことをやってるんだけど
結局話聞いてるんですね
そこでふざけて聞いてるんだから
わからなかったことはすぐ聞いちゃう
それでまあ説明してあげなくちゃいけないんです
そういう子はやっぱり勉強しちゃうんですね
だからこのわからないことはわからなくわかりませんと
そのことは何回聞いたってもいいんですね
それでもわからないんだと
先生は自分持ってる工夫は全部使って教えるかもしれません
それで先生のあの何箱全部工夫は全部終わっちゃったら
もうお手上げだと私にはそれ以上説明できません
先生言うかもしれません
それだったら他の人に聞けばいいしね
たまにあるんです 先生言ったことをわからなかったんだけど
隣に座ってる生徒に聞いたら教えてくれるとか
そういうことでしたって
なるほどと それもあります
それはやっぱり教え方というかね
なんか分からないなんでそれを私も
まあですからこのこの人がお釈迦様はそれは業ですよって
業によってこうこう人々は全部もう決まられてるんだよと言ったら
ちょっと先生わかりませんと
そう言っても だからわかりやすく説明してください
私はちゃんと理解して聞いてますと言ったら
じゃあよく聞いてください
説明してあげますと お釈迦様はこれからこの説明いたします
で一番目に出てくるのは摂生のことで
もし女の人か男の人かとか
このパーリ語っていうのは二千五百年も古い言葉なんですけど
皆様 アメリカ語でっていうのは英語なんですけど
書く場合は今Heとか書かないんですね
今の普通に何か書くと
例えばこうなればその人はこうなりますよと一般的なことを書くと
昔はHeという言葉を使っちゃうんですね
彼という言葉今は使わない
ひおしと両方入れなくちゃいけないんです
そうでないと差別したことになるんだと
だから嘘嘘を言ったら彼は罰を受けますよとは書いてはいけません
嘘を言ったら彼か彼女が罰を受けますよと書かなくちゃいけない
面倒くさいんだけど 僕から見れば
私でも書く場合は いつでもひという言葉を使ったら
必ずおしと書くんですね
ひすと書いちゃったらおはと書くんです
で でもこの経典を読むと
いつでも一には取りそうはと両方出てくるんですね
ですから面倒くさがらない方がいいなと思いますけど
でお釈迦様ももし男か女の人が殺生するならば
ローヒとパーに手でいつでも血が血まみれでというんですかね
手には血があるならば
はたパハで まああっちこっち武器を持ってニビッとアダヤーパンの全く優しい心はないと
生命に対して全く不親切で優しくない
もう平気で殺しちゃうと
と 男であろうが女であろうがって関係ないんです
で 我々もあるでしょうね
ゴキブリは見たとたんすぐスリッパが手に入っちゃうとかね
恐ろしいと思いますけどね
日本は平和な社会だからね
人を殺したりはできませんだけど
ゴキブリなんかはね なかなか見たらもう潰されるしね
だからそういうのを気をつけた方が私はものすごくショックを受けるのは
それを見ると なぜなら私に心は読めるんだから
私知ってるんです この人々がものすごい殺し合いの環境に持っていったら
平気で殺し合いするだろうと
だから心は危ないんだと
ライフも危ないんだと
だから まあ幸いにこういう風に大変行儀のいいしきだりのちゃんと決まってる平和な社会に生まれたんだから
もう悪いことしてないんだけど
本当にそういう そういう環境にいたらどうなるかと
ですから 心は清らかにするということは
やっぱり殺し合いしなくちゃいけない環境にいても
相手を殺さない心なんですね
ですから このローヒとパーに手に血がもう付いてる
いつでもそんな感じでいたって
我々には関係ないというふうには簡単には言えないんです
我々もどうですかとかね
顔を見るとすぐ潰す 潰すか自分を守ろうと頑張るかどっちかなんですね
まあ私たちも小さい時から仏教の文化で育てられたんだから
どうすれば蚊から逃げるかということをしか
蚊を殺すということを考えないんですね
私もすごくアレルギーみたいに
蚊にはものすごい反応を起こしますけど
ですからもう刺されたらすごく痛いんだけど
痛いだけじゃないんですよ
もう１日寝られないんです
その毒が体にある間は
それでも殺してやるそうとは思わない
逃げろと 逃げることは面白いんですね
動物と同じく ライオンがもう鹿を追っかけてるんだけど
鹿は一生懸命逃げて もう逃げたそうと
こっちにライオンいるんでライオンすぐ捕られるんですね
鹿はすごい また待ってまた餌を食べてるんです
ざまあみろという感じで
だからそこら辺がね なんとなくもう面白いしね
だからもう蚊から逃げるということをしますけど
殺そうという風にはいかないんですね
ゴキブリが入ったらどうすればこのゴキブリを追い出そうかと色々企みはするんだけど
潰そうとは思わないんです
潰すのは簡単であるし
殺虫剤でもかけちゃえばそれで終わりますからね
ですから やっぱりそういう風に心を育てた方がいいとは思いますけどね
まあこちらで まあこういう人がそうテーナカンメーニエワンサマッテーニエワンサマディンネーナ
もしそういう生命に対して大変不親切に残酷に生きていると
その人とは死んだところでアパーヤンドゥッゲテンウィニパータンニラヤンウッパジュティ
アパーヤってのは地獄ですね
ドゥッゲテンというのはものすごい不幸なところに行くんだ
ウィニパータンというのは堕落して落ちてしまうんだと
ニラヤンというのは完全な地獄
ウパパッジョ ウッパジョ
生まれるんだ いわゆる苦しみのところに生まれるんだと
ノーチーカーヤッサベーダ
もし死んでそういう不幸なところに生まれなかったならば
いわゆる分かりやすく言えば地獄に落ちた
落ちなかったならば サチェーマヌッサッタナーガッジョティ
もしその人はまた再び人間に生まれ変わったならば
ヤッタヤッタパッチャージャーヤティ
どこへ生まれたってもアッチャーユコホ
寿命は短いんだと 寿命は短い
アッパユクサンガッタニカエサマノパティパタ
それは自分の寿命を縮める
縮める道だと ですから
この世の中で寿命短い人も寿命長い人もいるんですね
で それはもうDNAだけのシステムで説明できないんですよ
なぜかというと 両親のDNA同じだから
なんで一人の子には寿命短い組み合わせと
もう一人に長い組み合わせでっていうのは
それはなんで偶然というのは非科学的なんですね
偶然ということは仏教で使わない
偶然だよ 全てに何か原因があるんです
偶然に起こらないんです
偶然地震が起こるわけじゃないんです
偶然雷落ちるわけじゃないんです
それなりの原因は集めたら雷が落ちると
我々原因わからないと
あ 偶然だと 偶然ということは
この科学者も使ってるみたいんだけど
それはもう完全に非科学的なんですね
いわゆる何か出来事が起きました
何か現象が起きたというならば
それにはそれなりの理由
わけ 原因 因果関係あるんですから
ただ私がわからない それだけのこと
ですから このDNAがね
小さい時組み合わせる時も
それは偶然だというふうに言うのは簡単ですけど
でもなんか訳があるでしょうと思いますよ
それは仏教でいうのはやっぱり自分の過去の選びなんですね
それで そういうことで寿命が短くなるんだと
そう言ったら なんかこのバラモンじみ若い人でしたからね
まあわかりやすく まあ殺生すれば寿命は短くなりますよと
覚えておいてくださいと
わかりやすく教えてあげたんですからね
まあそれはその人それなりに
またすごい長いお経ですけどね
理解しましたけど でも私はここでちょっと科学してみますからね
殺生するということはどういうことかというと
他人の生命を奪うことであって
他人の生きる権利を否定することでありますと
あなたには生きる権利ない
殺してやるということでしょ
ゴキブリをね 総理で叩く時でも
ゴキブリにはゴキブリの生きていて
寿命が終わったところで自然に死ぬ権利はない
それはもう早く殺してやると
ですから 生命はね まあどんな生命であれ
殺すっていうことは その生命にある生きる権利が奪うこと
自分で取ろうとするね
人の寿命を 取ろうとするんだから
自分から取られる それで自分には生きる権利なく生まれちゃうんです
心のそういうふうな法則なんですね
だから まああの自作の反対に引っ張られる
引き離される法則から見れば
もう生命を支えているんじゃないんだからね
生命のエネルギーは だから生命のエネルギーからもう
逃げを逃げをしてるんですね
その人から ですから もう例えば
こんなこと言っていいかどうかわかりませんだけど
白血病ですか 白血病とかあったりすると
だからその場合はどうなるかで
その同じ細胞同士で互いに殺し合いをやってるんでしょ
それで早く死んじゃうんですね
今は医学を発展していますから
もうなんとか治れる 治せることは治せますけど
でも全部治せるわけでもないんですね
なかなかね あの骨髄にぴったし合うものは 1万人に一人しか会わないんだから
それぐらい難しいんですね
骨髄移植して子供の場合だけどできますけどね
それも骨髄の問題で 白血病になった時だけ違う原因で白血病になったらどうしますかと
もしT細胞の場合 お互いにもう全部食べるようになっちゃって
細胞自体殺すわけにはいきませんだから
それだったら永遠にビニール袋の中に生活しなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
それで正しい生活と言えないし
2種類ありますからね
例えばこの白血球がもう全部赤血球を食べてしまうと
そうするとその細胞の数がどんどんどんどん増えていって
早く死んじゃう それでその人には薬をあげて
白血球を機能しないようにしてあげなくちゃいけないんですね
機能しないようにしちゃったら
その人には空気触れたらもう病気になって死んでしまうんです
空気にいっぱいばい菌いますから
それでビニールの部屋を作って
酸素も全部綺麗にして吸ったりして
母親にも子供を触ったりすることはできなくなっちゃうと
手袋をつけて触ったり
それで長生きしたっても
別に生きたいことにはならないし
それで骨髄の問題で白血球になったという場合は
もういわゆる赤血球は作れないという状態なんですね
その時は移植は効きますね
その時も 1万人の一人しかこれ合わないんですね
骨髄の方が それで手術したっても
100%成功するかしないかまたわからない
ですから大変難しいんですね
そこでまあ それはそれで病気の病気のことだから
私は必要なこと言っては私に罰が当たりますから
そこは置いといて 否定するわけじゃなくて
単なる分析してることだから
その人の体の場合は 体互いに殺し合いやってるんですね
そこで早く死んでしまっちゃうんです
支え合ってないんです
例えば 私たちは今までもうもう白毛になるまで生きていたんだから
白毛になってない人は別として
まあもう私は全部白毛ですけど
で そこまで生きていたんだから
どういうことかというと
お互いに助け合ってるんですね
細胞は そこでそこの外のウイルスやらばい菌やら細菌いっぱいあるんだけど
攻撃しない 体に入ったっても別に攻撃しない
それでそのままで仲良くしてるんですね
例えばエイズの場合も
エイズにかからない人いるんですね
エイズウイルス入っちゃったんだけど
その人に病気はならないと
で 体の中 エイズウイルスは元気にいるんです
その人ごとキャリア キャリアですか
キャリアという言葉で言ってますけど
その人から他の人に病気移るかもしれませんだけど
本人には病気がない あれ何なのかと
エイズウイルスというのは随分もう賢くて頑固で
一番今まで見つかっているウイルスの中で頑固なものなんですね
すぐ自分の遺伝子配列さえ変えますからね
細胞の中に入っちゃいますから
白血球に だからすごい頭がいいんです
外にいると食べられちゃうし
だから食べるものの中に入ろうと
そこまでいて人を壊しちゃう
人を早く殺しちゃうでしょうに
それがね それまたうまく仲良くしてる人々がいるんだから
体の中に やっぱり助け合ってるんですね
まあいいよ あなたもそこら辺にいてくださいと
私たちもそこら辺で頑張りますよと
お互いに攻撃しない 殺そうとしない
ですから このウイルスというのは完全に殺してやるという概念というのは
この西洋医学では出てきましたけど
インドの医学ではそれ出ていない
ウイルスの概念もないんですね
それも生命だから 生命を殺す殺す薬っていうのは人間に悪いんだと
その代わりにインドの治療法っていうのは
命にエネルギーを与えてくれると
自然の流れに流れをちゃんとしてくれるという薬なんです
もうこれ 同じく西洋薬と同じく効くんです
ものすごい早く ですから
それも考え方次第で 結構ヨーロッパでもほとんどそういう薬使ってますけどね
今は で あの たまにこのペニシリンとかね
注射効かない合わない人々いますでしょう
それでまあ自分の国だったら
お医者さんが何のこともなく
まあチェックしたらあなたに合わない
ですから うちに帰って
あの普通の伝統的な治療をしてくださいと
と言うんです もしかするとこの病気はね
まあ本当はペニシリンの働きは必要なんです
その人特別に何かウイルス活動してるんだから
でも普通のこの色々薬草とか漢方とかとかね
煮て食べて飲んだりしちゃうと
もうまた治りますから
ですから やっぱりその場合はどうしますかというと
その人にペニシリンが合わないんだから
やっぱりこの体に入ってる
あの 細菌なんかはもう攻撃しないように
もう仲良くしてくれる
その薬 薬によってというふうなことで
そこまでまあ話を余計なところに行きましたけどね
一応この我々殺生するということは
相手の生命に攻撃して殺したということ
相手の生きる権利を奪った
仲良く手をつなげて生きていきましょうという心理学的なことはなかった
お前は嫌だと 私は生きていけて
あなたはだから生きる
生きてほしくないと ということだから
その人はどこかで生まれ変わっても
その人の体の中で細胞が攻撃する
で そういう法則なんですね
それで 逆に生命を慈しみの心で考えて
生命を大変もう助け合って仲良くしましょうと
というふうに助ける人であるならば
いわゆる全く殺生はしないんだと
生命は奪ってはいけません
それでも頑固と生命を尊重する
尊重する 大事にする気持ちだったら
その人はもう生まれ変わったらすごい明るい人だから
大事にしましょうと 仲良くしましょうということだから
みんなその人を呼ぶんですね
こっち来てくださいと
ですから その人は生まれ変わったら天国に行くんだと
もし天国に行かなかった
向こうは幽体状態で行けなかった
もし人間で生まれ変わったならば
ずいぶん長生きするんだと
それからこの次にこのいじめること
もし人が手であら石やら
あるいはいろんな棒やら武器やら持って
他の生命にありとあらゆるいじめをしているんだと
怪我したり ぶったり殴ったりとか
そういう暴力的な性格をしていると
もしその人が人間で生まれ変わったらどうなるかというと
ものすごく病弱と だから他人の生命いじめた
他人の細胞をいじめたんだから
自分もすぐいじめられる細胞を持って生まれちゃうんですね
アトピーも一つなんです
いわゆるまあちょっとしたことで病気になる
ちょっと空気が変わったら病気になる
水が変わったら病気になる
食べ物ちょっと変わったらもう病気になると
そういう体が弱い病弱
何でしょうかと というと
やっぱりその細胞自体を持ってる稼働なんですね
他の細胞にいじめられる
ご飯食べたっても それもまた細胞だからね
いじめられる だから食べられない食べ物はいっぱい出てきたり
何か食べたら大変 もう体が壊す
壊る 壊すとかいろいろあったりとか
そういうのは出てくるんですね
で 病弱で生まれる人々は結構他人を他の人々をいじめた人々なんです
で どうしても信じがたいというならば
あの 大体このまあ寿命短い人のことをちょっと失礼だからね
まあ実験できませんだけど
もしあの早く亡くなった人々をね
もうあまり長い寿命なかった人々がいたならば
いたならばね その人々の性格をね
ちょっと思い出してみてください
なんかあの他人に対してすごいなんか失礼というかね
まあ生命大事にしないという
あの過去の癖ついてるはずなんです
病弱の人の場合も そういう癖がまたあるんですね
過去でやったことの そこはいつでもあの引き離せるエネルギーの心のエネルギーなんですね
自分に寄ってほしいものなんですけど
自分から逃げちゃう 例えば寿命短い場合は
寿命を長生きするためには
私の体の中の細胞ももう全部お互いに助け合って共同体で活動してくれなくちゃいけないんですね
そうじゃなくて もう私は別であると決めちゃったら
それでもうガンですからね
細胞もいつでも互いの周りの細胞とコンタクトを取って成長するべきかないかとか
いつでも計算しているんです
例えば怪我したら日目で治るでしょ
怪我は 怪我したらみるみるうちに怪我治るでしょうね
もし同じ速さでその細胞が成長したらどうなるんですか
どんどんどんどんそこで腫瘍が出てくるんだから
もうガンですよ で 不思議なことを怪我しちゃったら
すぐ細胞が新しい細胞が生まれて
元の状態になっちゃったらピタッと止まるでしょ
お互いにちゃんとコンタクトを取ってるんで
細胞同士で まあもうこれでOKですよと
で 壊れたら新しい細胞を作って
またこのもう建物壊れたらなんか修理するような感じで
もうどんどんどんどんそこはちゃんと直しちゃって直して終わったらまあOKですよと
もうやめましょうと そこでちゃんとやめてくれる
ですから ちょっとしたことで
でも病気 ちょっと怪我したことは
また悪い運命が悪い人にはガンになる可能性あるんですね
自分の田舎である あのばあちゃんがいてね
大変信仰深い学校の先生でしたけども
もう毎日もう説法を聞いたりするし
で 私にも大変いろいろね
面倒見てくれたりして
まあお母さんみたいな人でしたけど
で すごい親切にしてきたんですね
そこであのものすごい元気なんです
年なのは年なんですけど
なんかもう若い男の子みたいにもうすごい活動していて
でもすごい年なんで そこであのなんかどこかであのバスが出てきて
バスに乗ろうと走ってきたんです
そこでスリッパがずれちゃって
そこでもう昼間でしたから
もうアスファルトをあの古い形のアスファルトでしたから
昔話だからね あの太陽熱でちょっと溶けてあったんですね
そこで足にこれ引っかかっちゃって
ちょっとした怪我しちゃったんです
で それもう治らなくて
もう歩けなくなっちゃったんですね
で それ癌になってしまったけども
まあそれもう決断する前にまあ自然に亡くなったんだけどね
まあでもやっぱりその時僕はもう
まあそれは年のせいもあって
寿命もありましたけど
やっぱりそれでもうもうカルマも消えてあって
もう残りはないし それで細胞は共同体として働かなかったんですね
これ同じこと私にも毎日のようにあるんで
私もいつでも道路であっち行ったりこっち行ったり
もう裸足で で これでアスファルトを足につけちゃって
ものすごくもう焼けちゃうし
もう痛いし で また後でそれもうあの灯油で洗ったりしてたらそれで終わっちゃいましたけどね
あのおばちゃんにはそうならなかったんですね
だからちょっとした怪我したらその細胞が壊れちゃうし
そこで治そうと体がするんですけど
お互いにコンタクト取ってない
そうするとこの治る分が早く成長するでしょ
早く成長すると毛が成長することになっちゃうんですね
ちゃんと皮膚が出てきて
それで終わりっていうことにならない
だから我々の体の中の癌にしたっても同じことで
いつでも癌細胞現れますよ
もう二十歳過ぎちゃったらもういくらでもあるんです
あるんだけど まあできたものはもうお互い他の人から協力ないんだだからそれもまあもう死んでしまっちゃいますけど
で それで一人二人が成長するようになっちゃったら
まあそれでまあどうしようもなくなっちゃうんですよ
ですから このそれで寿命が短くなっちゃうということは
この互いに協力するということは必要なんですね
協力しないと 我々精神的にあっち行けという感じで生活しちゃったら
あっち行けという感じになってしまっちゃう
否定されちゃう 拒否されちゃう
他のエネルギーから 他のエネルギーから
ですから食べ物から拒否されちゃう
空気から拒否されちゃう
水からも拒否されると
いろいろあるんです それはこの寿命短い場合ですね
もう一つ二つ言いましょうか
もう時間になりましたけど
そこであの 長生きする人々は他の生命はいじめない
暴力は振るわない 暴力でも二種類あります
精神的な暴力と肉体的な暴力
どっちでも暴力なんですね
ですから まあ肉体的な暴力は皆様ほとんどやってないんだからね
まあ問題ないんだけど
やっぱり精神的な暴力結構振ってるでしょ
だからそこら辺も気をつけた方がいいんです
精神的な暴力はすごいキツいんです
殴っちゃったらもう痛いと
やめなさいと言って それで終わる場合もありますよ
でも口で痛めつけちゃったらもう全身で痛いんですね
それまたもう何年も残っちゃうしね
恐ろしいんです だからこの我々性格
態度 言葉 そういうものを持って人に暴力を振ってるんです
精神的な暴力 精神的ないじめ
それも確実に寿命を短くするものなんです
そこら辺もとことん気をつけた方がいいということ
そこで怒りっぽい人が
いつでも誰かに引っかかりたくなっちゃう
いつでも怒ると そういう性格だったら
生まれ変わったら人間ですごい醜いと
いわゆる人を惹かれるような美しい体では生まれないんだと
醜くなっちゃうんだと
あれ人を惹かれない 人を引き離せる
自分が怒りっぽいだから
怒りっぽいエネルギーっていうのは
この相手をまた否定するエネルギーなんですね
怒るっていうことはもう現象は否定する
だから怒る 否定するエネルギーですから
否定されちまっちゃいますね
で だから生まれると このDNAは出来上がっちゃうと
体の構造もそういうふうに否定されるような
いわゆる相手に構わない性格なんですね
それは俺でそれでいいんだと
でも我々の体できちゃうと
世界の他の生命と合うようにできてるんです
そうでなきゃ生きていられないんです
ですから この この そういう人々はもう他の生命ともう波動が合わないようになっちゃうんです
自分だけ生活しなくちゃいけない
醜いというのはそういうことで
それも同じ この引き離すエネルギーなんですね
で 例えば人間と動物 他の動物の生活を見ても
まあどこかで我々互いに何とかの感じでも合ってるんですね
で それでも生活はしているし
例えば鳥がいたって別に邪魔だと思わないし
家宅侵入罪で我々鳥を訴えようとはしませんしね
自分の庭の木の果物を食べていたってもね
これは泥棒やと言って警察に訴える人もいないし
まあどこかで我々合ってるんです
自分を植えたリンゴの木に
まあどこかから鳥が来て
これ食べてるとか なんか見てなんとなくまあいいんじゃないかとね
まあ綺麗やと楽しいという気持ちが出てくる
鳥もそれちゃんと知ってるしね
これ人間作ったものやとかね
そういうどこかで互いに合う
そうするとすごくうまく生きていられるでしょうに
だから動物の中でも人間に合う動物は大変豊かで成長するし
人間と気が合わない動物は殲滅状態になっちゃうし
人間に嫌われちゃうし
もうそういうことですね
ですからこの我々にとっても
この動物見ても 醜い動物と可愛い動物が出ちゃうでしょ
猫は可愛いと言ってずっと遠い昔から飼っているし
犬はすごい心がかゆいわいますよと思って
遠い昔から犬を飼ってるし
全然虎飼った人はいないしね
虎飼っていたならば 虎は今殲滅状態になってますけどね
殲滅しないのに やっぱり虎がどこかで人間と合わないところがあるんですね
本当は昔から飼っておけば
今も虎もちょっと大型の猫みたいで別に問題ないんです
アメリカのどこかでテレビで見たんだけど
なんかいろいろそういう虎やら凶暴な動物も預かって
あの あの殺すようになっている動物とかね
いる人がいて その人ともものすごい合うこと
お互いにこのベロを合わせられるんですね
虎とも 何のことなく 他の人は怖くても近寄れないし
やっぱり会う場合はもう会うんですよ
虎でもライオンでも蛇でも何でも
ですから この怒りというのは
相手が憎いと否定することで
それは合わないということで
ですから自分が合わないように生まれてしまっちゃうということは
人間の言葉で言えば醜い人間になるということ
で まあまあ 私は自然の中で育てるだから一回いっぱいそういうケースは知ってるんです
犬もいて もう子供たちが子犬を見たら
もうすぐ子犬を選んで行っちゃいますけど
誰にも選べ選べない犬たちがいて
野良になってしまっちゃうんですね
やっぱりどう見たってあー可愛いなと思えなくなっちゃう
それ知って 私はそういう生まれたすぐわかるんです
この猫は誰か必ず飼うだろうと
この猫は誰の面倒見てあげられないだろうと思って
私はわざわざとそういう猫たちやら犬たちのは面倒見たりもしましたけども
そこで面倒見ちゃうと
もうまたそこで会いますけどね
面倒見てあげてるんだから
でも人間っていうのはそこまで深く考えないでしょ
こいつ この猫を飼いますよって言ったら
すぐ感情でね すぐ見て可愛いと思ったものは買ってしまっちゃうし
その方が大きいんだから世界はね
ですから 醜く生まれちゃったらもう大変なことなんですね
誰にでももう可愛いと思われる風に生まれ変わらなくちゃいけない
そのためにはやっぱり怒らないこと
いつでもニコニコと笑って
何があっても怒らない性格を作らなくちゃいけない
そういうのは今世でも同じことです
例えば今日から怒らないと決めちゃったら
今日から美しくなってしまっちゃうんです
すごく可愛くなってしまっちゃうんです
その可愛らしさ 醜さっていうのは
また形じゃないんです
それも覚えておいてください
ただね もう顎が引いてるかないかとかね
鼻が出ているかないか
そこではないんです そこだけ見る人々はただのもうバカですからね
表しか見てないんだから
人のね 皮膚しか見てないんだから
でもいくら鼻がなくても
あまりにも小さくても
顔で鼻見えないほど小さくたっても可愛い人は可愛いんです
なんか誰かテレビで言うのを聞いていたんだけど
オードリー・ヘプバーンですか
あの大変日本ではね すごく人気ある昔のね
女優でしたけど 全然美人ではなかったみたいです
でも結構私もあまりにも日本で人気あるんだから
映画いくつか見たんですね
やっぱり可愛いんですよ
なんかあんな演技見てると何か楽しいし
なんかすごくなんか共感生まれてくるんですね
だからあれほど有名になったし
彼女の性格見たっても同じことでしょ
ものすごい優しい人で
最後になってもね もう死ぬ時でもすごい素晴らしい人格があって亡くなったんだから
単なるわがまま女優ではなかったんだから
やっぱりわかるんです
その場合 僕だったらなるほど
かっこつけでもすごいみんなに親切にして
全然怒らないで生活していたんだから
もう体はもう顔が四角四角いし
そんなにもうね もしかするとビューティーコンテストだったらもう予選で落ちると思いますけど
でもやっぱり大女優になってみんなに愛されちゃって
亡くなっても覚えているんだから
そういう世界にまるっきり無知な私さえ名前を覚えているんだから
ですから やっぱりそこはあるんですよ
ですから 怒らない人はものすごく可愛くなる
分かりやすい言葉では美しくなる
ですから いくらおばあちゃんになっても
いつでもニコニコとすごく心優しいおばあちゃんっていうのは
なんか見るたびにありがたくてしょうがなくなっちゃうんです
喋りたくなっちゃうんで
助けたくなっちゃうんです
ですから このそれは可愛く生まれる原因なんです
それから イッサマナ それから嫉妬する人
嫉妬する人は他人の幸福は嫌がるんです
嫉妬っていうのはそういうこと
他人がすごい美しいんだったらもう嫌がるんですね
それに嫉妬というんです
怒りと似ています でも怒りっていうのは別にもうどんなことにも怒りますけど
嫉妬という怒りはそうじゃなくて
人の幸福見てもうすごい嫌なんです
認めたくない ケチをつけたくなる
それは嫉妬というんです
男にも女にも誰にでもあります
で そういう人はどうなるんでしょうかね
アッペイサッコー なんかすごい小さな人格の
なんかこの 何と言いますか
そういう人々はもう存在感は全くない
誰にでもあんなんかなく無視される
[背景音楽]な この人生になってしまうんですね
やっぱり人間っていうのは存在感というか
あってほしいんです グループの中に入ったら
あ この人もいるんだとみんな思ってくれなくちゃ
まあそこら辺いるんです
いたんですかという感じだったら
何の存在感もない そういう人には決してリーダーには全くなれない
喋っても誰もまあ喋ってる
喋ったのという感じで聞いてないし
特にこのリーダーになるために
政治家になるためにすごいこの存在感が必要なんです
ある場所に行くと もう行く前からもうなんとなくその人のエネルギーが入っちゃって
なんとなく緊張感みたいな
すごい存在感ですね それはまるっきりない
他人の幸福 嫉妬する人
他人の幸福を嫌がる人にはそれはなくなっちゃう
いわゆる他人を認めない性格でしょ
ですから自分も認められない
人のことはよく見て ああ良かったんではないかと褒めたりすると
いつでも人のいいところを顕微鏡でも見て
あなたにこういうとこあって本当に良かったんですよと正直に言う人は
いつでもみんなに愛されるし
すごい存在感が出てくるんです
それは政治家には一番必要なものなんです
なぜならば たくさん人を扱ってるでしょ
だから その人の人がどんな才能を持ってるか
どんな能力を持ってる
それはすぐ見極めないと立派な政治家にはならないんですね
リーダーにならないんです
リーダーというのはたくさん人を自分の下で自分が引っ張ってるんですね
ですから 人々には自分のアイデンティティありますから
人の奴隷になりたくないんです
でも 例えばよく喋る人がいる
そこでリーダーがあなたは上手に喋りますから
あなたはこの仕事をしてくださいと
いわゆるみんなと関係を持つ
あの 何て言いますか 何リレーション
人間 そこはその仕事 その人に与えてあげる
あなたはすっごい鋭く計算強いですね
だったら我々のグループの全部名簿じゃなくて
何て言いますか この計算はもうそういうことをあなたやってくださいと言われると
その人々にもアイデンティティあるんですね
それはリーダーにはそれすぐ見極める能力が必要なんです
この人はみんなと仲良くしているんだから
じゃああなたはまとめ役をやってくださいと
政治家はそういう性格だったらものすごく成功する
普通のグループであろうとも
リーダーが人の性格をちゃんと見極めるとということだったら
もうリーダーシップを取れる
そうすると存在感が出てくる
その人について行ったっても嫌ではないんですね
なぜならば 自分の能力は出せるんだから
奴隷にされてる気持ちは全然しないんです
だから私よう通りにやりなさい
やりなさいとか 独裁的な人はリーダーにならない
ただ力で抑えてるだけですぐ爆発して壊れますから
ですから 独裁者はすぐなくなっちゃうんです
いくら同窓同窓やら作ってやったってば
全部倒しちゃうんです
それは後であまり時間経たないうちに力ある時だけ
でも本物のリーダーっていうのはもう 100年経ってもみんな覚えている
その人々の性格を見ると
自分を扱っている人々の才能をちゃんと認める
他人を認める だから嫉妬の反対の性格を持っています
ですから 嫉妬すると存在感はなくなる
嫉妬しないとすごい存在存在感がある
立派な性格ができると
そこで前も説明しましたけど
やっぱりみんなと物事持っているものを分けて
みんなにあげて みんなで使ってる
そういういつでも手を開いてやってるというパーリの言葉なんですけど
あげると 握ってるんではなくてね
そういう風にもうみんなと仲良く分けて分けてやって生活する人々が大変豊かになると
あげないで取ろう取ろうとしちゃうと
ものすごく貧しくなるんだと
これは先に説明しましたね
それすごい高慢だったら
ものすごい高慢で もう頭下げない
誰にでも尊敬するべき人にも頭下げない
なんでこの人に頭下げなくちゃいけないかと
そういう態度でっかくて高慢で
こちらタッドというものすごい硬い人間がね
どうなるかというと 彼そういう人々はこのレベル低いところに生まれちゃうんですね
いわゆるカーストの低いところに生まれちゃいます
それで逆にちゃんと年上の人を敬ったり
尊敬するべき人は尊敬したり
ちゃんと人々のことをね
ちゃんと挨拶して お互いにすごい礼儀正しく柔らかい生活
日本風に言えば もう体を曲げて挨拶するんだからね
そういうふうにすぐ曲げる腰と背骨を持ってる人々がね
で どこでも認められる
高いところに生まれると
高いカーストに それはいいかどうか分かりませんだけどね
皇室の人々というかね
あのもう天皇陛下とかね
見るとまあすぐもう頭曲げるでしょうに
天皇陛下なのに 皇后様もそうでしょう
なんかもう すぐもう人に挨拶する時
もう外国のいろんなこと見たって
なんかもう本当に天皇陛下ですかと聞きたいんだけど
ちょっとしっかりしろと言いたいんだけど
やっぱりそうじゃなくて
ものすごい丁寧に丁寧に
そういうのもやっぱり過去でもそういう性格でしたから
日本で一番偉いところに生まれてるんですね
それ上はないんですね
今はその性格 あるんだから
だから高慢じゃないんですね
だからみんなに愛されちゃうし
嫌な人だと誰も言いませんだからね
そういう人は一人もいない
我々外人から見ても なんかすごいなんかもう見ると楽しいというかね
あの性格やらね 歩き方やら
人と喋る時でもなんだかんだでも
あのこの間テレビで歌会ですか
それ見ていたんだけど
あんまり厳しくてもうガリガリ状態でやってるんだけど
やっぱりそれでも天皇陛下はいつでもちゃんともう
そこら辺見ると何か落ち着いちゃうし
人々の方を見ると落ち着きがなくなっちゃうんだけどね
みんなすごい硬いんだからね
緊張して やっぱりいつでも尊敬するべき人を尊敬して
頭下げるべき人に頭を下げて
高慢というのはまるっきりなし
という生活すると すごく人々に褒められるところに生まれ
生まれるんですね 人々に尊敬されるということ
ここら辺でまあやめなきゃもうキリがないんです
それからよく知らないことは人々から聞いたり
何か知らないともうイライラしたりとかして
やっぱり知るまで何とかしないと
だからもう態度置いといて
知る人のところに行って
これあなた知ってるんだから教えてくださいと
そういうふうなこの物事をよく聞く
質問する わからなかったら正直にわからなかったんだから
もうちょっと説明していただけませんかとかね
それで真面目に聞く そういう性格ある人はいつでも自分の頭を磨いてるんですね
それだったら どこ生まれたって磨いた頭で生まれるので
ものすごい咲いてる心で生まれるんです
だからこの頭のいい人々を見てください
いつでも好奇心があるんですね
これ 日本でもものすごい抜群に知識のある
もう天才みたいな方々いるでしょ
性格を見てください 子供みたいんです
好奇心はもう年取ってもあるんで
歳になっても 喋る時も子供みたいに
ああそうですか すごくまた面白がって
ああそうとそれまた読んだりしたりして
ですから それ過去生から続いている癖で
もう 高慢じゃ私は学者だからあなたに言うことは聞きませんよと
それはないんです 私もガキの割にいろいろ先生たちにいろんなことを言ったりした覚えがあるんですね
あの先生って あんた何も知らないんだからあっち行けといつでも言わなかったんです
ああ そうですかねと言って真面目に考えるんですね
考えたら 私は言ったことがほとんど
たまにほとんど間違ってるんですね
その時もあんた間違ってるんじゃなくて
でもこういうこういうことから考えるとどうでしょうかと言っちゃうと
僕はやっぱり私が間違っていましたとわかります
その時もやっぱり先生の性格のありがたみを感じるんですね
いきなり私を捨てないで
よくも聞いたんだと それで真面目に考えたんだと
考えて 自分がそのいろいろ情報を組み合わせたところで
私の意見は良くないとわかったんだから
だからやっぱり知識ある人はもうずっとそういう性格を持ってるんですね
知識ある人はほとんど本当の知識人がもうすごい柔らかいんですね
すごい好奇心を持っていて
そういうことで ですから
知恵 知恵で生まれたければ
知識で生まれたければ
いつでも質問したり 人と相談したり
自分より頭のいい人と付き合ったりする必要あるんだと
高慢で私は聞きませんと言ったら
もう無知で生まれちゃうし
そこで今の無知な人は今世に生まれたっても人の話聞いてないんですね
心に鍵かけてるんですから
鍵かけてるんだから情報が入らなくなっちゃう
そういう風にこのこのバラモン若者にお釈迦様はこのカルマの法則を教えてあげたんですね
ですから それは人間がどういうふうに生きていればラッキーになるか
どういうふうに生きていればアンラッキーになるかという話なんです
すごい長い複雑な話なんですけど
一応磁石の例えで覚えておいてください
2つあるんだと じゃあ
時間になりましたらすみません
どうもありがとうございます